So far, you've used the APIs Explorer to investigate and test the functions in
your applications. You've got the getProfile, the
safeProfile. However, Conference Center application includes a full
web UI. Each of the pages in the web UI, send calls to the endpoints
API on the back end. As you implement the back end functionality, the web pages
in the app will start to work. Right now,
they don't all work. For example, if you go to
Show Conferences, it's not going to find any conferences.
It's because the implementation, because you haven't written the code
to find conferences. But in this lesson we implemented
the code to get and set profiles. So the My
Profile page now works. So let's see what happens,
if I change my profile. Let me change my t-shirt
size to, very small, extra small. Change
my display name to Jocelyn B. I'll Update my profile. And
the profile has been updated, excellent. When I click the Update Profile
button, what happens is that this web page in behind the scenes is sending a
call off to the saveProfile endpoint function
that you just implemented. The goal of this
course is to help you learn how to
develop App Engine applications, not to teach you JavaScript.
However, I do want to point out the code
that makes the call to getProfile and to saveProfile.
So, now here we are in Eclipse. And you'll find the code for the webpages or the
web UI under SRC, Web app, and you'll see
there's the CSS folder, the fonts folder, the IMG,
there's index.html, and there's a JavaScript folder
JS. And then there's this thing called partials,
which is the HTML pages. What I want to look at first is controllers.js, because
this has the code that calls the
getProfile and the saveProfile methods. So let's look
at getProfile. So here's the code that
send the call to the getProfile endpoint function.
And you see here, it's gapi.client to
invoke the client library. And then, conference
is the name of the API. And then, getProfile is the method name. And again,
we execute. And then, here's the code to call when the request is successfully
executed. And in this case, you can see that the code's just right here in line.
It's not in a separate function. That this is the callback to call when the call
to getProfile succeeds. Let's look at saveProfile. I'll search for it.
And here it is. And again, I just wanted to point out, here's the call to
gapi.client, or gapi.client. And then conference is the name of the endpoints.
Then saveProfile is the method to call. And in this case we're
passing at one argument. And then we call the execute, to execute the
request. And again, here's the call. Here's. The code to
execute in the call back that's called, when saveProfile
completes successfully. If saveProfile completes successfully.
So that's all I really wanted to point out here. I'm not going to go into the
rest of the UI code in detail. I just wanted to show you the hook where the
JavaScript issues the call to the endpoint functions.
As you go through the course, you're going to be
implementing the endpoint functions. And I wanted you
to know how they get called from the UI.